we have heard of temperatures like zero
degrees Celsius which is the freezing
point of water and 100 degrees Celsius
which is the boiling point of water
though Celsius is a more common way to
measure the temperature Fahrenheit is
also sometimes used as its unit of
measure zero degree Celsius is the
equivalent of 32 degrees Fahrenheit
there is a particular way in which we
can convert Celsius to Fahrenheit and
vice versa
this is the formula to convert Celsius
to Fahrenheit we multiply the
temperature in Celsius with nine over
five and add 32 to it and modifying this
formula we get the conversion from
Fahrenheit to Celsius subtract 32 from
the temperature in Fahrenheit multiply
it with five and divide the entire thing
by nine so how much time do you think
you'll take to convert one to another
twelve degrees Celsius is how many
degrees Fahrenheit or 23 degrees
Fahrenheit is how many degrees Celsius
look at it a bit practically if somebody
asks you this in real life they are not
expecting a perfect answer what you need
is an approximate value using these
formulae will give you the perfect
answer but you take too long to arrive
at it so let's see a quicker way to
arrive at an approximate answer let's
say you want to convert Celsius to
Fahrenheit all we need to do is multiply
the temperature in Celsius with two and
add 30 to it that will give us the
answer in Fahrenheit say 10 degrees
Celsius we need to convert this into
Fahrenheit multiply it with 2 and add 30
20 plus 30 is 50 degrees 10 degrees
Celsius is approximately 50 degrees
Fahrenheit multiplied with 2
and add 30 to the product 17 degrees
Celsius 17 times 2 is 34 and 34 plus 30
is 64 17 degrees Celsius is
approximately 64 degrees Fahrenheit if
we do the exact calculations using the
formulae we would have got 10 degrees
Celsius as 50 degrees Fahrenheit yes we
were a bit fortunate here and 17 degrees
Celsius as 62 point six degrees
Fahrenheit almost equal the higher the
temperature the bigger will be the
difference say 50 degrees Celsius 100
plus 30 is 130 degrees Fahrenheit the
exact answer is 122 a difference of
eight degrees Fahrenheit and converting
100 degree Celsius to Fahrenheit we get
230 degrees approximately and the exact
answer is 212 degrees Fahrenheit so as
the number increases the difference or
error in the answer also increases thus
this work for negative temperatures as
well absolutely say minus 15 degrees
Celsius minus 15 times 2 is minus 30 and
minus 30 plus 30 equals 0 minus 15
degrees Celsius is approximately zero
degrees Fahrenheit the exact value comes
out to be 5 degrees Fahrenheit so to
convert from Celsius to Fahrenheit just
multiply by 2 and add 30 to the product
and how do we quickly convert Fahrenheit
to Celsius easy we subtract 30 and then
divide by 2 take 100 degrees Fahrenheit
for example we subtract 30 and get 70
and 70 over 2 is equal to 35 100 degrees
Fahrenheit is approximately equal to 35
degrees Celsius the exact answer if you
calculate is
thirty seven point seven seven seven
eight degrees Celsius the difference
isn't much what about 72 degrees
Fahrenheit subtract 30 and get 42 42
over two is 21 72 degrees Fahrenheit is
approximately equal to 21 degrees
Celsius now let's try converting minus
40 degrees Fahrenheit to Celsius
subtracting 30 we get minus 70 and
dividing it by 2 we get minus 35 degrees
Celsius approximately the exact value in
these two cases is 22 point 2 to 2
degrees Celsius and minus 40 degrees
Celsius a very small degree of error in
each case but what if you forget the
ways of conversion remember for the same
temperature Fahrenheit is always larger
so multiplying it with 2 and adding 30
will definitely give us a larger number
to convert from Celsius to Fahrenheit we
multiply and add and as Celsius is a
smaller number we subtract 30 and divide
by 2
one good way to remember this is that C
comes before F so C is smaller than F
[Music]
you